heading back to shore the team reviewed
the footage from cameras mounted on the
bait lines
so that's when the boy went down
look at that oh it really wanted to
think this is awesome oh it tears it up
with no claspers visible
the shark is a juvenile female and new
to the Atlantic white shark database I
think we put this one at like nine
right yeah I think so a nine or ten
footer so not a super big one still a
big shark but not really big for a white
shark do you think this typical size you
guys are seeing up here it seems to be a
lot of the juveniles a lot of the
acoustic detections we get it's it's in
that
um you know let's say 9 to 12 foot range
it's the smaller guys yeah
it's an important clue
and different to the pattern Greg and
Megan see some 260 miles to the South
around Cape Cod
we do see juveniles but a lot of our
resident sharks are big males and those
big males may be schoolyard bullies you
know pushing these
smaller animals into other parts of
their range which include in the summer
and the fall Canadian Waters
in 2019
a drone operator captured sharks
clashing off Cape Cod
territorial adult males
be pushing smaller white sharks North we
also know there are social interactions
between these sharks because we see
scars you know there are bites there are
injuries that are clearly from other
sharks and is that associated with
mating certainly it could be but it on
juveniles it could also be associated
with negative interactions between
sharks in other words get the hell out
of here this is my neighborhood
territory may just be part of the puzzle
of what's drawing sharks North
Canada's Atlantic Waters have some of
the richest fishing grounds in the world
sharks in the eight to nine feet range
are youngsters and for the most part
fish Hunters
the shape of the seabed here combined
with the cold Labrador current as it
mixes with the Gulf Stream brings
nutrients up to the surface
it makes for the perfect conditions for
marine life to flourish
in spectacular numbers
Canada is also experiencing one of its
hottest August on record
could the mix of so much food and
warming Waters
be part of what draws white sharks North
[Music]